welcome to this video playing town
tavern from the UK I checked this ride
and forgotten no no name okay let's see
okay it's not going for a stone wall but
phone um semi Slav entire Marin let's
let's see I don't know this opening too
well only know the the general kind of
setup twinbee 80s and then a 6 and so on
let's see I think III okay he lets me
play before they have caused their
others there are ideas will see 5 even
this one of those okay let's see I guess
it isn't
interesting this I didn't really fear so
much I thought this should be should be
good for for a little something question
is still how to play it cannot play you
for which is good okay like to make sure
that h2 is not a problem yes I thought I
can take and Queen f5 so let's see just
sort of putting up multiple attack b5
hangs and ii fibers under pressure and
the night hangs and there's no g5 so
there are many things happening at 1cm
oh wow poor Michael Knight g5 Knight f6
oh it's okay i can just take here I told
us the big idea and now yeah push up
chicks here probably I've won a pawn and
b5 is weak but not clear to me what what
is doing now I also have the simple idea
to put the Queen to f5 and to capture d5
and I he just blundered this I think to
Queen arrived if I don't know maybe
there really wasn't a good move possible
I mean everything so everything was
hanging at the same time okay what what
is this what can you do here yeah okay
of course I cannot take now as then
there's bishop h2 at the end so we need
to improve my web pieces if i take here
at Bishop g5 and i still this check out
let's prevent the check that's useful
anyway add the funniest thing is I can
still take because Queen takes Bishop g5
is a fork on a two went to see six as
well yes right but I have this one I
thought now I don't see don't see a good
reply to that Bishop c8 a look-see eight
maybe now should be should be enough
did even with opposite colored bishops
it's um it's it's it's really it's quite
a number of points already ok check 27
no no no no I need to get the rookin how
does he defend against this weight g 6
and Queen f6 is this is winning
wait I really don't want to spoil this
now yeah it must be it must be good no
to it to attack here cannot believe it
this one cannot sec here right
roop rook c8 there is no win hard to
believe but it seems to be the case
amazing okay rook c8 we are making it a
bit more complicated than necessary
probably but it might also be just the
best moves it's possible it's sometimes
a hot call between keep it simple and go
for the maximum black resign yeah yeah
he really does not have a move here yeah
Queen Queen here for example check this
one and there's always this he does not
have any play against my king so it's
it's probably probably probably just
okay i'm not i'm not really aware how to
play this this type of position i guess
this is my be an idea i'm not sure that
if either so good i don't i don't really
think this is helping let's see this
this type of position for example this
is just just okay we can also take with
this and then go for for this type of
type of thing i think this is better
than you five if I've is not not like a
terrible but and this is I don't I don't
I don't really see what what he's doing
after this 95 is just a mistake i think
it's it's it's really hard to make a
move now I mean there's so much hanging
maybe this one yeah that that's also a
big problem even something like this
it's just it's just not it's just
stopped really working out who black
this pieces are not not really
coordinated it was probably still better
than
this which is probably probably just
lost against good play yeah this was
still possible even after you get you
and after that did some it's probably
just oh um okay thanks for watching